Hi everyone.
Welcome to the first week
in our series of classes.
In this tutorial, we're
going to take a look
at how you can use a flatbed
scanner, believe it or not,
to create some very fine images
of three-dimensional objects,
like microfluidic devices,
Petri dishes, and other sorts
of material you're creating
or working with in the lab.
Now you might be
wondering why we're
starting this course with
a tool that you probably
wouldn't think of
for creating really
fine images of your work.
Well, we want you to experience
the fun part of creating images
at first, and
frankly, we wanted you
to start off with some easy
stuff-- well, relatively easy--
and not having to worry too much
about technical issues, which
believe me, will come later.
That's a promise.
This course is
meant to encourage
you to capture your material
in a number of ways.
And probably most important,
to learn to see in the process.
So you're seeing, and
will continue to see,
all sorts of images that I
made on the flatbed scanner
with different approaches.
I'll go into detail for a few of
them in all of these tutorials
and we'll call
them case studies.
You'll see things
that will surprise you
and you'll discover
new perspectives, that
is new points of
view, which might
lead to new thinking
about your work.
Try out your ideas
about imaging.
It won't take long.
That's the nice part
about the flatbed scanner.
Some of your ideas will
work, and some won't.
Believe me, a lot of them won't,
from my personal experience.
And emphasizing what I said
in the general overview,
most of this is
about experimenting,
or in a way playing.
The process, I hope, will
become an active discovery,
as it did for me when
I made these images.
You should think of this
process in a similar way
as you do with your
own investigations.
So using the scanner can, if you
choose, come close to imaging
with a microscope, if you make
sure you capture your image
at a high enough resolution.
You can start zooming in to
your image on your screen
and see things that you
could not see with your eyes.
And I'll show you that
a little more later on.
One thing-- I wanted to let
you know that I digitally
cleaned some of these images
so that your eye wouldn't be
distracted with dust particles.
That's important
for you to know.
The decision of whether to use
a flatbed scanner is yours.
First think of the size of
your device or material.
I'd say a safe bet
is, if you're planning
to see details from
a few millimeters up
to a few centimeters.
But as you'll see
in a few moments,
you'll be able to capture detail
in the 30 to 50 micron range.
What you'll see and
show in your image
will depend on how you set
the resolution in the scanner
setting.
For the time being, just think
about it this way-- the higher
your DPI setting, that is dots
per inch, the more information
you're sending to the sensor.
The more information
you're sending,
the more detail you'll
be seeing and capturing.
You'll find all about this
in our HOW-TO-DO-IT tutorial.
Take a look at that after you've
completed this week's tutorial.
You'll see how changing the DPI
settings, as we are seeing here
in these three images, will have
a direct effect on capturing
details.
Why use it instead of a camera?
Well first of all,
you can very quickly
make some very fine
images without going
to more complicated
setup with your camera,
as you'll see later
in the next few weeks.
You can show evidence
that you've made something
or that you're
observing something.
You might want to show
a part of something
larger, a small
structure for example.
You'll be able to share
some observations quickly
with your colleagues.
You can consider
it as a draft image
that you will eventually use
in a figure for a submission.
Perhaps you can even use the
image as a patent submission.
That's something to think about.
The wonderful surprise
here is that you
can put a three-dimensional
object on the scanner
and create images that suggest
their three-dimensionality.
Yes, you will lose
depth of field,
which we'll discuss in the
next tutorial about cameras
and lenses.
But still, eventually
you'll create sometimes
a knock-your-socksoff image.
Hopefully you're interested
in that sort of thing.